that moscow is easily reached from
leipzig and dresden prince herman von
portland moscow wanted to create a park
here that looked like an art gallery
with something new to marvel at with
every few steps his idea has become an
artwork in itself combining nature and
architecture on the banks of the river
nicer
you can see an idealized landscape
stretching all the way to the horizon
there are no barriers borders optical or
acoustic interference
fundamentally that's
active approach to landscape design
which the park still embodies
and it's very enjoyable
even if we're not surrounded by
germany's major cultural centers
after world war ii the german polish
border cut the park in two much of it
was destroyed
since the fall of communism in 1989
germany and poland have cooperated to
restore the park the so-called english
bridge has been rebuilt based on its
original designs since 2011 it has
connected the park's polish and german
sides
there are two central bridges linking
the two halves of the park
you really need both bridges in order to
follow the pathways pukler originally
envisioned for the park
the ruler designed the park in the style
of an early 19th century english garden
its layout provides uninterrupted views
of carefully placed bridges
the neo renaissance newcastle was once a
royal residence now it is home to a
permanent exhibition about the prince's
life and work
a cosmopolitan with many interests
he loved making an impression
and he certainly did that with moscow
park
it attracts some 300 000 tourists a year
it's roughly the size of 800 soccer
fields
you can explore the park in a
horse-drawn carriage
in a boat on the river
or by bicycle
guided tours take place on a regular
basis through the entire park or
tailored to individual subjects
visitors learned that the prince altered
the course of the nicer for his park
resettled an entire village and planted
eight hundred thousand trees
we're the beneficiaries of pickler's
vision
it can't have been as beautiful then as
it is now
it's been quite an experience
fantastic we definitely have to come
again
the joint efforts of germany and poland
were rewarded in 2004
when muscal park became a unesco world
heritage site
it's a superb example of how
understanding and cooperation can
succeed in a unified europe